WONG
Don't cast that spell.
It's too dangerous.
DR. STEPHEN STRANGE
Why?
We tampered with
the stability of spacetime.
The Multiverse...
...is a concept about which
we know frighteningly little.
MORDO
Your desecration of reality...
...will not go unpunished.
♪♪
DR. STEPHEN STRANGE
It was the only way.
But I never meant
for any of this to happen.
♪♪
[Raven hisses]
[Birds chirping]
♪♪
[Shears snipping]
DR. STEPHEN STRANGE
Wanda.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Well, I knew sooner or later
you'd show up.
I made mistakes
and people were hurt.
DR. STEPHEN STRANGE
I'm not here to talk about Westview.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
Then what are you here for?
DR. STEPHEN STRANGE
We need your help.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
With what?
DR. STEPHEN STRANGE
What do you know about the Multiverse?
♪♪
MORDO
I'm sorry, Stephen.
I hope you understand.
The greatest threat
to our universe...
...is you.
DR. STEPHEN STRANGE
Things just got out of hand.
♪♪